I had a there were a couple questions
from the internet but I figured we could
just start with kind of what we were
talking before about education in
general sure so as you're a dad now and
you're thinking about education having
now you know been at Cooper Union yeah
on the board of Cooper Union I've been
at the Media Lab and now kind of the
shed to interacts with that you know
education and art in the kind of
cultural way yeah and that it's value
yeah how do you think about higher
education for your kids in 20 years yeah
so yeah we have 16 years before my
daughter is released from the American
high school system into you know who
knows what really and I think that there
are I we talked about this a little bit
earlier but there it's basically 15
universities a year that go bankrupt in
the United States there's a lot of
reasons for that but one of them is that
maybe it's just simply the model as they
have constructed it and are sort of
buttressing it to keep it exactly as it
has been maybe that's maybe that's no
more appropriate for education than it
is for many other things in our lives
you know it's you know it's arguably
easier to change the the sensibility of
a city than of than of a a university
because cities people leave and
universities the the people who really
determine the the core sensibility of it
are tenured in which there's there are
very good reasons for tenure and it
arose under McCarthyism to protect free
thought essentially which is great but
if you if you look at the downstream
effects of protecting free thought such
that then only the people who
got caught in that particular net are
preserved and the question is what are
the what are the downstream effects for
everybody else within that and how do
you how do you start with that the
bottom line is is that I think academic
institution the bottom line is is that I
think academic institutions and cultural
institutions have this thing in common
which is that what they what they
provide you with is a sense of
continuity between you and some larger
set of people and ideas we if you if you
didn't have cultural institutions and
you didn't have schools in the
contemporary United States there's not
there's not that many things that are
accessible to most people there's a lot
of abandoned churches we don't work in
factories or offices the way we used to
so there's not the same sense of
community there so I think the the role
of these of institutions whether it's
the shed or Cooper Union or MIT or or
whatever I think what they provide is
some you it is for the thing that they
do is they pursue to acknowledge that
you are not an individual know that you
that you exist in some broader context
um that hopefully you're helping to
shape and hopefully is a is a positive
context right I mean it's not dissimilar
do I see we were talking about this yeah
before but I think that that batch
structure yeah even though they're so
close together you know it's like three
months apart between the winter and
summer version but still you're like you
know I'm winter 17 your summer 17 like
we're in the same alumni cohort and
that's awesome right but I'm still
summer 17 I'm tight with people in that
way I was thing about it just yesterday
because I you know I was thinking I was
thinking wow you know like I have two
friends who've never even met each other
who just got MacArthur grants
and I have another friend who just
released this beautiful beautiful work
like the Franklin's who just did the the
paperclip game that is really Ranieri
awesome and some amazing work when was
when Hawk and what and I just thinking
what you know like I it's not that it's
not that I'm in all of their work at all
it's their work but all of their work is
in me like I like like you know through
my friendships and relationships with
them hmm you know that that is that's
what makes me who I am I have I have no
illusions of that that the ideas that I
have or the capabilities that I have or
the or the knowledge that I have comes
from me it comes from it comes from
being connected and embedded with an
amazing group of people
hmm you know sent through Cooper Union
or it's through its three of like I've
had it I've had a really really
peripatetic journey in my life and so I
it's possible that I've crossed through
more industries and disciplines and so
on then than on average we don't
normally talk about this but I actually
think folks would be interested in you
giving a little bit of the back like she
could connect the dots in the yeah and
then the the usually in meetings that
I'm in you know it's like if you know I
had a meeting yesterday with the Cisco
hyper location crew and you know and
we're talking about how to do indoor
positioning systems and you know and I
was and I was talking about signal
attenuation through steel versus
concrete and listen that and and at a
certain point the guy from Cisco said
you know like you you know a lot about
this what did you study and and this is
always the punch line is sculpture I
study stuff like that and that's and
that's actually the only thing that I
ever went to school for was sculpture
and everything else are things that I
have been sufficiently interested in
motivated by and/or capable of a
acting and engaging with people who were
brilliant in other disciplines mmm so
you know I'm working on I'm working on a
project this is the last project that I
have at MIT that I can't exactly I can't
talk about what it is but it's it's I'll
just say it's a it's a it's a it's a
very large scale artwork that is that's
using that's using CRISPR and you know I
know fuck-all about how to get that done
I now know just a little bit but what I
what I do know is I know how to work
with people who are really good at their
craft and I know I know how to connect
them and I know how to draw out their
best work I think I would I would say
that I would say that I'm good at
drawing out the best work out of people
is that an innate quality or is that
something you've cultivated I don't know
I think I think I I think at a certain
point I became aware that that's one of
the only things that I'm good at and so
now I now I now it's very deliberate you
know everybody but I think I think you
know I think it comes from from really
valuing what other people do you know
like you know I worked for years with
with with Frank Lance when we had a
company called area code where we I mean
we I can say like we legitimately
pioneered some of the earliest examples
and and an actual products etcetera in
location-based games like you know when
nobody knew what that meant you know
when you still had to pull you know
cell-site signals off of towers right
wailing we had to negotiate with
carriers for for location data right you
know we were doing all that but the
thing is is is that Frank was basically
my favorite game designer and I think it
comes from really valuing that and like
not like it's you know it's not trying
to
the difference between managing people
and actually drawing things out you know
and I and I think I think learning how
to learning how to learning what
brilliant people there's an art to
getting brilliant people to surprise
themselves and that is that's what I
that's what I try to do that's what I
have tried to do in most all of my
endeavors and is that because I mean
I've worked on a handful of projects
with people that I think are absolutely
brilliant amazing and more often than
not it's because I'm like hey I have
this particular skill set you have this
particular skill set I think you're
amazing and you know part of like the
the sales process or the meeting sick
I'm just kind of fawning over you yeah
yeah yeah it's super cool and I can't do
it yeah what did you provide in that
relationship because I think certain
people who feel like they can spot
talented people also feel a little
inadequate and a little like an impostor
and they don't know how to add value
yeah well that's a good question I think
there's a couple things that I bring to
it one is one is I usually bring the
beginning of an idea or often I bring
the beginning of an idea so you know for
example this this project I can't
describe is you know I had I had an idea
that I couldn't even begin to articulate
and I brought that to a pretty hardcore
computational biologist that I know and
she turned it into a much richer idea
and then but it was also beyond her
ability to do it but then you know it's
like but then it kind of snowballs right
then it's me and her mm-hm and we go and
find the floral geneticist who can
really pull it off yeah and then so
that's part of it is is the kind of
snowball like you can't you kind of like
you find the person who can add that
much to it and then the person who can
edit that much and then so each time you
meet somebody you're bigger and it's
richer and I think the other thing that
that I've been good at is is that I
can I'm very good I think at
demonstrating the value of whatever it
is we're doing to somebody who has some
money to pay for it
yeah just bottom line and that you know
I think I think people who were really
really good at whatever they do are
often not in a good position to be able
to do that because it requires a level a
certain level of detachment from what
you care about to be able to look at it
from somebody else's point of view and
to be able to tell a story about it that
isn't the story that you tell yourself
necessarily it's a true story it's just
not the story that you tell yourself and
you know I in my travels I among other
things I spent eight years in
advertising
and I learned I learned a lot about how
to how to tell a story and I learned a
lot about how how how ideas can provide
value basically so now do you fundraise
for area code
no we just Frank and I just boots draft
we just we totally did that it was it
was just two dudes in a room with some
savings okay and you know we were
anomalous we were you know I think I
must have been III guess I was like
thirty five Frank was probably maybe 38
or so right you know silly totally
anonymous but it meant that we had some
saving you know we had the savings that
it'll put away mid 30s people might have
so we were able to to to kind of like
deal with it well because of the
question I was wondering is if you had
raised on the entrepreneurial side yeah
much you know VC standard versus you
know raising at MIT or are you involved
at the Shedd no fund raising I am okay I
am so yeah how how does a story differ
when you're trying to you know pitch a
different product people might argue
this and I don't I don't even know if I
believe what I'm saying but I think
probably I would say that the that the
essential story that you have to tell
when your fundraising is a story of
scale right like like because the
premise of fundraising is is that the
money is going to scale and that means
something else has to scale to produce
that scale right and that and so that's
that's just the bottom line right is is
that this is that you're telling a story
of growth and the best the reason that
area code grew and we grew to roughly 40
people by the time it was acquired its
money alone the reason it was able to
grow is is that that just we weren't we
weren't trying to we that we just it
just was not it wasn't a priority we we
we were just trying to do the best work
we could do and and we would just grow
as we had to and if we'd had to think
about growth from the very beginning men
we would never have done anything we did
you know we would you know we would have
bet it all on on this idea that we had
in 2004 that we we went and talked to to
the Nintendo Corporation we had this
idea for Pokemon we probably would have
bet it all on that right and what a
mistake that would have been yeah right
right it works right so what ended up
being the big success of area code um re
code so for in terms of the the things
that we did there were a lot of there
were a lot of like little successes um
like you know and you know we were area
code was this is very unusual beast and
I and they're very I don't I don't think
there's been many like it before after
which is that normally if you want to
make money in games if you want to make
a living in games you say like I'm gonna
build a shop that's optimized for you
know triple-a console development you
know which has nothing to do with the
shop that you would build if you were
doing like you know iOS development you
know it because the level of engineering
and and an expertise etc is so intense
for existing clamors if you think back
to when we started 2004
everything was just [ __ ] up like the
hood like like it was like it was like
the very end of
of like flash-based casual games yeah
right like that was like those were sort
of tailing off and and the console
industry was sort of didn't know what it
was doing I couldn't quite figure out
what the next big move was and mobile
just didn't exist yet in the United
States and and so it meant that what we
would we weren't a game development shop
yeah we were a game design shop and that
is insane
because what we would do is we would
just we would pick up technologies or
ideas that would fall off the back of
different trucks and we would hold it up
and we'd say like what what does this
mean if we play out like what you know
okay so you know what is you know so
cell-site sector location like that
means you know that you're within like
three blocks of this tower like like
what kind of a game would you build for
that which is totally different when in
2006 maybe I think we got we got in the
States
our first phones that had a GPS chip in
them there was only one it was a Boost
Mobile is just a terrible handset and we
had said we had you know we were like
getting j2me it was I thought it was it
was so it was so difficult and so awful
it was it was so difficult just to get
the handsets because the idea that like
you know we needed like 20 you know for
testing the idea that there would be 20
handsets in lower Manhattan you know
that people would buy that a GPS like we
had to we had we would have to wait a
week for new shipments it was like it's
just so we would just every new thing
that happened yeah
we'd be like what could you do with that
what could you do with that what could
you do with that and the reason that
that's insane from a business
perspective is is that the efficiencies
in that are exactly zero right you had
you it's like it's like it's like it's
like basically you work really really
hard to solve all of these problems
technology problems design pattern
problems all the problems of making
essentially the first game where you're
running through the streets tracking
your location
yeah and then and then we're like and
now let's now let's do a game about
synchronous watching with TV
and we you know start again just throw
it all out right because there was no
business to build on there so we were
like okay what's the next thing what's
the next thing what's the next thing so
the success of area code in retrospect
is that we just we would just arrive
everything that arrived we met it and
towards the towards the end of it the
things that arrived started to scale and
the two things that arrived five years
into our into our project like like
after five years of really kind of just
like wow is that this is it this is it
this five years in iOS arrived and we
were like oh we'll make an iOS game and
and then and then Facebook games start
to happen just really just just started
to happen and we we built one that was
insanely successful by early Facebook
stands like like we're basically
everybody that we knew on Facebook was
playing this game is called parking wars
is a game about parking your car it was
but it was brilliant like it came it
came out of Frank's head it was it was
it's actually one of the it's actually
one of the the most beautiful games that
we made there and and one of the most
successful but the but so the the sort
of accidental success of Airy code is is
that the because we met everything when
it was knew when to knew things had
unimaginable scale an unprecedented
scale that was that they were that they
were unlocking we became experts at
launching into those unknown spaces and
so that was that was at that moment in
2011 that was very valuable to a lot of
different companies who hadn't been
trying to get into those new spaces
because their game development shops
what they're trying to do is just
optimized for what they know yeah are
you tapped into the gaming space right
now not not certainly not in as an
industry oh and
well I'm just curious what you what your
thoughts on basically the new
technologies right yeah people seem to
be bullish about VR yeah what do you
think I think that there will be some
great games in VR I haven't seen one yet
I think that broadly speaking everything
that I'm seeing in VR games is basically
done by people who made console games
and where they're essential mm-hmm
mode is thinking in console games if you
think about how long it took cinema to
stop just putting people on a stage and
filming it you know to realize that you
could cut you know I mean really it's -
it's true yeah it took a long time right
and then wait and then when they did the
first cuts you people were like wait a
minute like I don't even understand yeah
what the [ __ ] I was looking at a train
and now I'm looking at a person you put
some text and and that moment hasn't
happened yet now which is which is fine
it's it's very early and you know but
but that that that person or that
company I don't think has has emerged
yet and I don't I don't instinctively
and from my experience I don't think
that that person is gonna come from one
of the big triple-a studios because
they're gonna have to be thinking in a
different way you know they just they
there's no I don't think there's I don't
think there's anything to be gained in
looking at VR as a wraparound console
right yeah I mean you just think about
how quickly the tech the technology
outpaces the education right so you know
I went to NYU and I was like an English
program so you're doing all this
creative writing not at any point was
there a course offered on how to write
for binge TV right like and now it's
like a whole industry right right exam I
don't even know if any Film School has
something like that right now
and so how do you write a narrative for
VR right and yeah I mean well well also
you know games aren't narrative vehicles
in general right I mean they're there I
there's a whole it's a whole very nerdy
set of ideas around games and
narratology which we're not going to get
into but but what I if I if I think
about it actually having had a minute to
reflect on it I can't remember the name
of it but somebody did a game where you
it this was just it was just some
independent developer it was a game
where it's for multiple players and one
person is trying to defuse a bomb and
they're on there looking at that in VR
and they're trying to then VR and
everybody else has the plans and they're
trying to communicate to the person who
is trapped in a helmet basically right
and so the you know the game keep
talking and nobody explodes that's what
no that's a different one actually
that's a new one but but yeah that's
that's actually I think a modern
instantiation of something that was
about three three years ago okay and it
was very it was very raw it was very
rough but but it was like it was like
right like maybe what the materiality of
the medium of VR should include the fact
that you're wearing a [ __ ] helmet
like you know and you're in a room with
other people for hate like like maybe
that's not like like maybe that's not
something to write off okay like maybe
that is maybe that is like you know one
of the essential aspects to play with
right you know the fact that you can see
things that other people can't see and
they can see things that you can't see
right like maybe you know one of one of
the research assistants at at the Media
Lab is Greg Bornstein who's now there's
now a proper game developer
and he did some early experiments around
he did a game called casein Molly that
was like the very first it was like very
early oculus and it was like it was like
one person with an oculus one person
with a mobile phone out in the world and
they have a they have an audio signal
between them but the the person in the
rift is can get some access to some
information about the streets and vice
versa and they're basically trying to
negotiate the fact that they are
separated which is a you know it's
partly it's not partly it is an explicit
reference to William Gibson's early the
Neuromancer in which case and Molly you
you know have in which in which Gibson
was very interested in this idea that
when you were in cyberspace
you weren't somewhere else right and and
and that a lot of things would be
happening there and that there would be
some interplay between them they're not
the same thing and the fact that they
are so different is maybe part of what
makes it so interesting you know and so
so I think there's I mean that's just
one example of like the ways to think
about VR and play in a in a way that's
not porting conventional modes of
interaction yeah exactly because then
you know you you spend all this time
thinking about games thinking about new
technology thinking about the future and
then an acquisition happens yeah and
then you somehow end up at the Media Lab
yeah right yeah and so how did that what
transpired to make that transition
happen yeah and then how did being at
the Media Lab affect how you think about
building products yeah yeah just good
questions I mean so I mean the answer to
how the transition to the media live
happened is is super dull which is that
they they they asked me why and I
applied and then they asked me to
comment I can't I I wasn't I wasn't
looking for it but also I knew some of
the people who were there I was
I was close with Neri Oxman who runs the
material ecology group and and so that
was sort of informed my sense of what
the Media Lab might be and they had a
sense of me in part through through the
relationships that I had and but it was
an interesting if you know it was really
interesting because then I arrived and
you know they're very happy that some
you know there's a new faculty member it
was very different you know that there's
this you know I was there for four years
and and one of them one of the most
interesting things about hiring new
faculty at the Media Lab is like the the
primary criterion is is that they're a
misfit right and it's like we're we're
looking for misfits who are thinking
about how to ensure the heritability of
CRISPR engineering right right like
because that's not a discipline that's a
person right and and that's actually
what the Media Lab is looking to hire
they're looking to hire disciplines that
don't exist yet that are hiding inside
the minds of a person you know and but
so the problem is how do you like what
is the what is a scaler they're
basically how do you Scout and how do
you even establish like what like what
what auntie discipline are you like
where does it go and so and so like the
the best way to describe the way the
searches go it's when I finally I didn't
understand how I got there until we went
to get other people which is that you're
basically you you know you kind of map
out the spaces of where all those 30
people are and then you just look for
somebody who is equidistant from all of
them right like like you know it's like
if they're if they're too close to this
one we have one of those yeah I know and
so and so I think for for the Media Lab
they they were really looking to try to
figure out games and play and that's
what I had been doing with area code for
for seven years
it's also true that when I got there
they were like everybody was like I got
there I got there in 2013 and everybody
was like we are so excited for you to
make keep making location-based games
you know and urban whatever and I was
like but that's that's not research
that's just that's just that's just
gonna be an industry like that like it
was you like I didn't know that that's
what we we were doing in 2004 but it was
research yeah 10 years ago yeah right
and like the fact that it's new to you
doesn't mean that it's new right like
and and if I was interested in scaling
that again I wouldn't try to do that
there and so for me I came to the Media
Lab to figure out you know they brought
me there because I was you know somehow
orthogonal to you know like you know the
30 different planes that are represented
that but I went there to figure out
what was similarly orthogonal to
everything I already knew and did so I
did some some game work and and brought
in brought in some some pretty brilliant
games folks and we got we got some we
got some interesting work done on games
but I would say within within 2 years
you know I had become just totally
interested in in microbiology and and
that's what the next two years really
looked like okay I was was was really
sort of revisiting the the ideas that
were underneath area code for me but not
how would you express those ideas in
terms of play but how would you express
those ideas in terms of biology mm-hmm
and I can't really say what you know
it's it's not it there's no there's no
straight path I you know I could I could
construct a clever story right but
but but it was it was instinct and the
instinct was was for the idea that
cities are not as simple as hardware and
a bunch of users that's just not that's
not what they are and when we started
area code the what was underneath it was
we're gonna build software for cities
right like that's how we talked about in
2004 I think now that's a that's a
powerfully banal idea right like if it's
like Italy like a meaningfully banal
thing to assert but in 2004 we were like
what is software for cities like what
would it mean to change your sense of
the city like and and we were reading
we weren't reading we had we had well
read all the work from the Situationists
in the 50s and 60s you know people
artists primarily philosophers who were
looking for strategies to to to get you
to reimagine you know the cities that
you were in you know we we we didn't go
into it to do Facebook games or any of
them more so yeah yeah I mean there were
we found something very interesting in
that but but when we started it was
because cities felt like something like
like that's at the time in 2004 is like
well that's something that technology is
gonna affect in 10 different ways it's
going to affect logistics it's going to
affect traffic it's going to affect
policing how will it affect play right
and so when I got to the Media Lab what
I I was sort of I was I was sort of
digging underneath the work that I that
we had done I'm trying to figure out
what was important to me about it like
if I if I were to reboot all these
things and they didn't generate
location-based games what would they
generate and it turned out that they
generated some investigations into the
notion of cities as biological super
organisms
um that like you know to to understand
that you know if you if you step all the
way back and you just look it's like you
know you look at termites you know they
make mounds that look like this and you
look at ants and they'll make colonies
look like this and you look at humans
and they make these weird super stress
and why you know like like what is it
about our you know essential trajectory
yeah that produces these things you know
across you know many different cultures
across long long swathes of history like
like what is it and there's super
interesting work by Jeffrey West at the
Santa Fe Institute really studying
cities as a complexity problem and
really really beautiful work about how
they scale and so on but through a
series of very weird tangents which is
what the Media Lab is is good at what I
became interested in was I had I had a I
had a a a hobbyists interest for a long
time in in in the gut biome crunches
which is now
weirdly popular right it's like it's
like now everybody talks about their gut
by but I I was you know like I talked
about poop long before poop was like
Congrats
right thank and and and the role of your
gut in terms of I I'm not so interested
in it in terms of like your health and
well-being although I do care and I have
a two-year-old so now I think about it a
lot I think about poop a lot again but
but what I'm interested in is just how
it reshapes your notion of the world to
know that you know you are a collective
organism right you know that that you
know there's all kinds of ways to
represent this and there's always you
know it depends how you measure things
but but one way or another
the majority of the DNA you know you
doesn't it's it's not it's not you it's
not from your parents you know and much
of it we literally don't even have a
name for it right like like like where
you know there are there are species
that live inside us without them we're
dead mm-hmm
without us they'd have to find somewhere
else to go and that should change what
we think of when we think of an
individual man I'd been thinking about
that a lot and this is all a very
roundabout way the only way I know it's
a roundabout way to get to the question
of if I have a gut biome let's distinct
from your gut biome does New York City
have a gut biome that's different than
the gut biome of Tokyo or Lagos or or
you know wherever and if those gut
biomes are different why are they
different and what is it what does it do
and what does it mean and in that the
gut biome that we have it you know comes
through the exchange of material living
material with the environment
mmm you know what does it mean to live
in one city or another it's you know you
are effectively in exchange with that
city this is why it's why you get sick
when you travel right you know it's like
it's why you eat the food that you know
in some city that you've never been to
you eat the food that everybody else
there yeah but no problem and it caused
you problem it's because it's because
you are literally carrying your country
your city of origin with you and and
it's it's incompatible lightly and
compatible with the city that you're in
right so seemingly this can this project
could have expanded you know like you
are the hub maybe in the Media Lab or
your cohort of people yeah like well I'm
just gonna go everywhere in the world
yeah and I'm gonna do tangible
scientific research but instead you're
like I'm gonna go back to New York where
I'm from and I'm gonna work my cultural
I did yeah yeah I I you know I think
it's exactly the point like we I for
that project which was around like the
you know figuring out
a discipline that is now a couple years
later called urban metagenomics you know
I amassed this amazing group of
collaborators and some of them were like
very very hardcore biologists it's like
really you know the top in their field
and some of them were like amazing
artists like Chris wolken and we weren't
trying to write a paper you know like we
were trying to effectively publish a
poem you know like the we what I was
trying to communicate wasn't data mm-hmm
it was an idea
hmm and that that is a very and that's
and that's basically that's what that's
what culture does right like you know
basically it transmits ideas and rather
than information okay and and you know
in that distinction it's it's not like
they're in opposition but culture is
distinct from information and the Media
Lab is really really good at information
and I had to figure out the right
environment for me in terms of how to be
expressive in terms of culture and at
the Media Lab the way they they would
always we would always draw this
diagnose or quadrant of you know there's
there's artists and there's designers
and there's scientists and there's
engineers and I don't know if it was
ever explicitly stated but roughly if
you brought less than three of those to
the table as an individual you weren't
you're not that interesting to the media
lab right like I'm overstating it maybe
even miss stating it but but but that
model of artists designers scientists
and engineers and it took me a while to
understand that my what I what I was
doing for myself and for the Media Lab
was basically representing the artist
and design piece of that half of that
and bringing
artist art and design I wasn't the only
one but I was bringing art design to a
scientific and engineering environment
it's not the Massachusetts Institute of
culture it's you know it's like fun
defensively right it's technology but to
bring art and design into that you know
with the deliberate goal of finding the
finding finding how to blur those
boundaries or eliminate this battery I
understand my role here at the shed and
I say it explicitly is basically
bringing the science and engineering
back you know this is essentially an art
it's it's a it's a cultural environment
it's it's not really designs art but
figuring out how science and engineering
play a meaningful role yeah and have
meaningful forms of expression within
within culture is it's like it's it's
it's basically the inverse of what my
job was a lab it's it's nice to be home
into her crown and also the opportunity
this is the first cultural center the
shed the shed is the first cultural
center to be at scale to be built in New
York City since Lincoln Center okay Wow
which is one 60s okay I guess it's
embarrassing I don't know but but Robyn
yeah like it's it's at least fifty years
ago okay
and and so the opportunity to literally
be part of that process of building the
institution yeah is too good to pass up
I you know I'm really I mean I'm I'm
good at the beginnings of stuff like
like you know and this is the beginning
you know this is an instance if the
building is still under construction so
so so part of it is is that it's the
opportunity to just to just it's the
it's it's the it's a it's a new cultural
institution for New York City you'd be
crazy to pass that up but also part of
it was the opportunity to work
it's the artistic director who prior to
this had been the artistic director of
the armory and had done a bunch of shows
there that on paper are obviously bad
ideas and then you would go and and they
were just they were they were
unbelievable shows you know like uh ends
I mean curator effectively yeah yes yeah
yeah he's a yeah in we have for
performance you'd call it you they call
it programming which means something
different here we have producers and
programmers but they don't do what you
think that yeah yeah I didn't even
realize that he was sort of like the
secret uh brain behind some of my
favorite things you know I you know it
was years ago is actually four years ago
just recently a show that was the
filmmaker Adam Curtis versus massive
attack playing live an obviously
terrible terrible idea and it was it was
so beautiful it was it was so
extraordinary and it was it was
legitimately risky mm-hmm
and I think it is it's just so rare that
I mean these days it's just so rare that
anybody takes an authentic risk of any
kind but I think it's it's it's maybe
even especially true in culture you know
I think you know especially you know
like large-scale cultural institutions
are weirdly risk-averse and to my mind
these days and so the opportunity to
work with Alex and the opportunity to
work at the very beginning of this thing
the building is designed by Diller
Scofidio and Renfro Liz Diller and also
the Rockwell group Liz Diller is an old
friend and
and and one of my heroes she's the
architect who did the High Line among
other things right and the shed is right
on the High Line and you know they she
came up with the idea of a building that
moves yeah you know and it's one thing
to come up with that idea and kind of
like sketch it and whatever and they're
like you know like they're actually
weird you know like we're building like
we moved it about a month ago for the
first time and nobody nobody got killed
a million eight million pounds moved at
about twelve miles an hour
and and nobody died it's amazing yeah it
kind of looks like like a concept car
that actually made it to production
that's well said I I knew and and also I
took a tour recently with with some
pretty hardcore folks from NASA's
Voyager engineers and we were sitting up
top looking at the motors that move the
building and and and one of them said
like you know this is this is ambitious
and it's like it's like if you're the
systems integrator on the Voyager and
you're looking at a building and you can
you call it ambitious that's an
ambitious building right so it's an
ambitious building and it is tabula rasa
yeah and it also has this very weird
quality I didn't realize how strange it
was until I started working here about
four months ago which is that it's a
it's an exhibition space of five stories
three enormous galleries you know sort
of like white box galleries really large
and then a very large performance space
and then two small theaters and Alex
when I first came in said you have to
understand this is very unusual
it's basically never done that you have
a combination large-scale performance
space and exhibition space and I sort of
didn't take it seriously because it just
sounded but if you think about it yeah
you you haven't been in a place like
that like you're not gonna go see opera
at MoMA I'm not gonna go see an
exhibition at the Brooklyn Academy of
Music Ram those things and they're never
going to happen
couldn't happen even if they wanted them
because they are built around doing the
thing they do so it took me a while to
realize that it's that it's that it
really is unusual then I had to
understand why you would even want that
and there's a couple different answers
but the most valuable answer I think is
it's what allows us to you don't start
with a format mm-hmm
you start with an artist or you start
with an idea and then you figure out
like what does that become and that that
will produce new forms and like and I'm
down for that like like I think I think
that is like that is so necessary so
important and so [ __ ] difficult
because that's the third part of it is
that there's also a reason performance
spaces with like there's a reason known
many moving buildings well putting aside
the fact of the building moves it's also
like the best way to make it real like
how few efficiencies you get in having
an exhibition space with the performance
spaces yeah think about what it's like
to get a ticket to go see the you know
Rauschenberg show at the MoMA yep and
trying to get a ticket to go see
Hamilton okay now think about one
institution that has to accommodate both
of those and what what is the ticketing
software look like really like there's
always like just that like like and and
that's that's like this big yeah yeah
and like so there's a reason the the the
analogy I always give is like you know
helicopters float in the air and planes
float in the air but nobody is like wow
it'd be a better plane if it also had
huge rotors in the top or you know is
like no they're they're different
they're different for a reason and they
operate differently for a reason but our
bet is that it's worth the the the
struggle of of making it's not just that
the building moves it's not just that
the building is weird it's that the
notion of the institution you know his
weird it's like it's weirder than
anybody knows
can you put the the risks you want to
take in tangible terms yeah yeah there's
some yes somebody some that I I could
tell you about the risks that we're
going to take in the programming would
you have which I know right it's a year
and a half year and a half there's gonna
be a show that is gonna be it's gonna be
extraordinary we might have to do round
two yeah yeah it's a show where I can't
imagine how it's actually it's like if
you're if you're setting something up
and you really you cannot imagine what
it is actually going to be at the end
that's exciting and like that like
that's risky and this is it's very it's
it's a very beautiful risky work with an
artist that I can't reveal yet but a we
are we're planting a flag with the first
show that says this is this is the 21st
century and it's not like it you know
it's but it's not it's not neutral you
know it's not it might not be pretty but
it's gonna be important and loud and and
and rich so there's a lot of risks in
the programming some of it is riskier
than others
but part of my role is there's a couple
different parts of it one of them that's
very important to me is to start
commissioning scientists to do work in
the museum and like even the idea of
commissioning a scientist is stupid and
probably destined to failure but maybe
not but figuring out how so so I'm
working with a scientist I also can't
reveal but one of my favorite living
scientists too to bring something to
life in 2019 that
what we're aiming for in that is is that
this is a scientist who sees the world
differently than you and I do you mean
cause of their work and everything
they've done up until now is trying to
describe that world in academic papers
and instead we're going to bring it to
life and that feels pretty risky to me
but then putting curatorial stuff aside
one of the things that we're gonna do is
eliminate any form of paper tickets
right it's basically your your tickets
gonna be your phone oh cool okay
and by 2019 that's ninety eight percent
ninety eight percent of the United
States will have smartphones even Obama
phones or smartphones you know you won't
be able to buy a non smartphone in 2019
and so that's gonna be your ticket and
it it allows so there's a bunch of
things that happen with that and wait
and they're they're basically mmm in
most ways just plain better then right
you know waiting on a long line and
there's a window and like you know
you've been to Times Square you see like
people with umbrellas in the snow
waiting for and it's just like you know
what it's 2019 and we say [ __ ] that and
we have no legacy infrastructure like we
have no incentives yeah to do any of
that so it's your phone but now here's
what's interesting if all those people
aren't online to buy their tickets or to
pick up their tickets where are they and
so now we have to think about that and
that's a problem that no institution has
ever had before right
like you know is if you don't have
everybody who is waiting to see the show
standing in the line what are they doing
and we have some we have some thoughts
about you know we I I only noticed it
when I was looking up the flow numbers
and I was like I was like whoa two
hundred people an hour what are we going
to do with the two hundred people who
were waiting like that we
have it so so so we're gonna be doing
some things that it it doesn't feel like
a big idea to just have your ticket on
your phone but it turns out you're
changing the entire experience of guests
and it actually changes how we program
the spaces so like you tweak that and
all of these sort of pry or is that you
have for culture institutions yeah go
out the window with it yeah so that's
that's one of the big risky initiatives
and then the other that I could talk
about is when I first got here four
months ago
the architects reviewed with me a
bulkhead on the on the the the north
east corner with cables that were going
to come out and a broadcast truck would
come up it has a satellite dish on the
top and and PBS or CNN or whatever they
would be able to live televised the
events that we do in the shed like they
do sometimes with the Matt or whatever
and I just you know I looked I was like
I was like guys did likelihood that in
2019 that truck is gonna show up is
basically zero right it's like it's it's
not it's not absolute zero but it's very
low yeah that those trucks are going to
show up to broadcast a live signal from
cables off of a satellite to television
sets that people are sitting at who
can't wait to see this thing you know
while everyone could watch it from their
phone on there like ticket device right
right right and so and so and so we so
we killed it
well the reasons is because we the the
architecture team had the insight to put
in an unprecedented amount of bandwidth
for a cultural institution it's it's
it's the first time I've ever been part
of any kind of architecture or something
where you look on you're like yeah
that'll probably work for the next 50
years like that's probably enough you
know like you know we're we're I
actually can't
you're out how to how to max it out like
lately like you know like like you know
we could you know I guess we could mine
Bitcoin yeah like I don't even know like
I don't even know what we can do with it
all but but but what we can do with that
bandwidth is basically do digital
broadcasts and that the idea of doing
live digital broadcasts not incidentally
but like as the core ethos of what we do
at the shed where this thing that we're
gonna do in the first weekend it's gonna
be it's gonna be enormous but I don't
know maybe in total over one week we'll
be able you know twenty thousand people
will pass through those doors right and
it just doesn't sit right
you know it just does it like that just
doesn't it just doesn't work for me and
then you have you know whatever it is
now three or four billion dollar four
billion addressable broadband
connections out there in the world that
we should you know we should be thinking
about it less of a building and more
like a beacon you know like this thing
that emits a live synchronizing signal
to everybody around the world I don't
want to I don't want to put it up on
YouTube I don't want to put it up on you
know it's like it's not about the
archive of it it's about that at seven
o'clock on Thursday this thing is gonna
happen you know and I'm sorry if that's
7:00 a.m. in Tokyo and you know whatever
like wake up early yeah we're gonna have
to make it worth your while
right you know like we do for the World
Cup right like like you know like I want
a you know because what is valuable
isn't just the performance and the event
what's valuable is that synchronizing
signal yeah and that to come back to the
very beginning of our conversation that
I think is the the most important thing
that cultural institutions can do now is
to basically provide synchronizing
signals is basically to say like you
know right now like we're gonna gather
together and we're all gonna be on the
same [ __ ] page you're like to the
next two hours
on the same page like for the next two
hours our attention is on this thing but
I'm here with you right and to and and
to be able to provide that feeling of
being with people at the same time with
the same attention it's very very
powerful I think it's generally
unexploited in technology in general and
it's definitely under-exploited in
culture yeah you know if you look at
what technologies do and have done is
they basically delaminate whatever it is
that we like from its mode of
transmission or expression whatever and
if we didn't if we didn't love that so
much
it wouldn't have worked right but it
turns out we don't want to buy albums
and we don't want to let you know like
that like we want that you want the
stuff yeah okay it's true we do but also
we want to we want to feel what it's
like to be connected to you know in a in
a kind of limbic way like in a like in a
in a in a in a synchronised way and so
so we're you know it's that's the it's
the premise of theatre it's like one of
the core ideas of theatre but the idea
that we will be a will be producing very
very high-end live cultural events for
the internet constantly feels like well
yeah that's that's probably what you
would do in the 21st century but I don't
know because nobody's ever done you know
how long's doing you notice right so
could talk about attention like the
separation of mind and body get our work
yeah but you know we've been going for
it like almost an hour now and so I just
kind of wanted to wrap up with one
question about you enjoy - cool yeah
you've done so many interesting and
seemingly different but connected things
10 years from now
what are you working toward - let make
make heaven better
I hope 10 years from now I'm actually
still here at the show
and that you know there were there were
some things I liked okay by advertising
when I worked in advertising for eight
years there were a bunch of things I
hated that there was one thing that I
really loved and I was so afraid to
leave advertising because I loved this
thing so much and this thing was I had
no idea what I was gonna do tomorrow
right like you know I you know you'd be
working on like some breakfast cereal
account this is like a real thing that
happening is that you're working on
breakfast cereal and you're like there
until eight o'clock at night because
advertising is hard and and then you
come in the next day and they're like no
you know what actually you're on the
f-22 fighter bomber and it was like it's
like wow like now I have to learn
everything about fighter bombers and how
people in Congress buy them you know and
and I thought when I left advertising I
was gonna give up on living a life in
which every day I've got to figure out
something new that we've never figured
out before and somehow that I think the
the the projects and positions and even
types of companies that I've been part
of making they all have that in common
and I think I like I sort of don't care
what I'm doing in 10 years as long as I
as long as I get to you know exercise
that muscle I I think at a certain point
I had to abandon the notion that I would
ever have legitimate domain expertise in
almost anything really but that my but
but if I could figure out how to work
effectively and and with real
capabilities between everything as
everything is arriving all at once that
that turns out to be valuable in the
world whoo which was surprising to me as
an adult it turns out to be valuable in
the world and also it's like you know I
feel like as
as you're doing something for the first
time you're still young right and so
like I just in ten years I just want to
feel young right so that's that's that's
my long I think we should just close it
right there all right thanks man yeah
you